the gyro can experience people are
losing their [ __ ] minds there was a
video from the University of Phoenix I
think it was where there's this kid on
campus and there was some pro Trump
group did you see that video that kids
screaming and you the same [ __ ]
fascist [ __ ] crap you're out to cut
and he's screaming and he's walking away
from them screaming and making this you
should all have your throats cut just
completely unhinged and I was watching
this I was like II Majan if this was
some kid yelling about Obama and the
Obama administration and the Liberals me
because he's not saying anything he's
not saying the reason why I hate you is
because you detained children at the
border in cages let's play this I could
hear it and play it and give me some
Bach okay that poor kid needs a hug yeah
but imagine if he was saying that about
Democrats every Republic or every
Democrat can suck my balls every
Republicans slashed every Democrat
slashed her throat that would be crazy I
mean he's doing that because there's a
pro student Trump organization there and
so he's screaming that unhinged that's
one of the problems I think we should
not give you know like we should not
give the right legitimate reasons to be
complaining about disparate coverage
right so one of the things that Eric
Trump tweeted yesterday was which I
didn't even know happen like apparently
a van was was was driven into a GOP
tents or something and you know they
were one of the primaries and it got no
coverage i I didn't until I I don't I
don't know but it's there was a story
about this and and you know Eric Trump
basically tweeted saying that imagine if
the labels were turned it was just the
other way around right we would hear
non-stop there will be analysis
of you know the far-right problem in
America and yeah so we you know the
responsibility is on the media to make
sure that these people don't have the
argument right the media has to be open
and they have to be unbiased in their
depictions of these things and we don't
really have that kind of media anymore
we have left-wing media and right-wing
media and everybody else is going what's
going on is this who's right he's
telling the truth you flip back and
forth from CNN to Fox News it's like
you're in a vortex of space and time you
don't understand what's what right yeah
it's weird but that kid screaming that
poor kid
like what happened where'd you get this
slot every Republicans slashed their
throat come on man who are you what
happened to you and you're in school so
you're learning something I'm so I'm so
weary of a sort of dogpiling on this
stuff now i think i think when i first
you know started on twitter - I I was
always in flaming like or like
retweeting something that was like oh
look at this super on the fringe and I'm
like no no maybe I shouldn't you don't
amplify that signal maybe maybe this
really is a French and that and that you
know I'm just kind of making it seem
like it's a it's a bigger issue because
I I noticed I fall into that trap
sometimes like that was this one story
that came out I think when Apple
released the new iPhone there was like
New York Post was like you know iPhone
10x or something was excited as was
criticized as being a sexist and I say
what why how how you know and it
apparently because like the phone was
kind of big like they expanded the
dimensions and so like it doesn't fin to
women's hands and as neatly yes the old
version did and then I was like psych
tweeted that angrily like yeah of course
like everything sex is again like checks
notes you know iPhone sexes and and then
I realized that was kind of part of the
problem because when I looked into this
whole issue it was literally just like
to Twitter egg accounts and so like an
article was written based on like what
somebody who's anonymous said on Twitter
that was sexist and it could have been
the internet research agency in Russia
just [ __ ] with everybody yeah or
catania it is it is so I kind of stopped
doing that stuff
I decide become bit more responsible my
own Twitter account
[Applause]